FOLKS, THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IS ALMOST
UPON US AND I FOR ONE CAPTAIN
WAIT TO SEE WHO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ELECT NEXT FOR JOHN
BOEHNER TO SUE.
OF COURSE, FORMER FIRST LADY,
FORMER SENATOR, AND FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE HILLARY
CLINTON IS THE CURRENT
FRONT-RUNNER, WHICH IS
SURPRISING SINCE IT SOUNDS LIKE
SHE CAN'T HOLD DOWN A JOB.
( LAUGHTER )
NOW, SECRETARY CLINTON SAYS SHE
HASN'T MADE UP HER MIND ABOUT
WHETHER SHE'S RUNNING YET, BUT
ME THINKS SHE DOTH NOT MAKE UP
HER MIND YET TOO MUCH.
LET'S JUST LOOK AT THE FACTS.
ONE, SHE'S ON A NATIONAL BOOK
TOUR PUSHING HER MEMOIR "HARD
CHOICES."
TWO, SHE'S EXTREMELY QUALIFIED.
THREE, LET'S FORGET ABOUT NUMBER
TWO AND JUST FOCUS ON THE BOOK
THING.
WHICH, BY THE WAY, FOR THE
RECORD I DON'T GET.
SURE, IT'S BEEN ON THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" BESTSELLER LIST FOR SEVEN
WEEKS AND HAS SOLD MORE THAN
500,000 COPIES WORLDWIDE BUT I
RECENTLY PICKED UP THE AUDIO
BOOK.
I LIKE TO LISTEN TO IT WHEN I'M
ON THE TREADMILL AT THE GYM
RAGER-SIZING.
HERE'S THE COLBERT REVIEW.
HERE'S MY REVIEW.
THIS BOOK IS 656 PAGES OF
SHAMELESS NAME DROPPING.
JIM?
>> TANZANIAN PRIME MINISTER
MIZENGO PINDA AND I DO SOME
PLANTING AT A WOMEN'S
COOPERATIVE IN MLANDIZI.
>> Stephen: THUD. DID YOU CATCH
THAT, TMZ?
SHE JUST HAPPENED TO BE HANGING
OUT WITH MIZENGO IN MLANDIZI.
NOT IMPRESSED.
SO SHE'S TIGHT WITH THE PRIME
MINISTER OF TANZANIA.
I HAPPEN TO BE E-MAIL PEN PALS
WITH THE PRINCE OF NIGERIA,
OKAY?
THAT REMINDS ME I SHOULD
REALLY-- I SHOULD WRITE THAT GUY
BACK.
SHIWRITE THAT GUY.
( APPLAUSE )
GOTTA WRITE HIM.
HE OWES ME A TON OF MONEY.
AND THERE'S MORE.
>> THE FIRST TIME I MET THE
BURMESE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE WINNER
AUNG SAN SUU KYI IN 2011, WE
WERE BOTH WEARING WHITE.
>> Stephen: REALLY?
WEARING WHITE AFTER LABOR DAY?
OBVIOUSLY, HER NOBEL PRIZE
WASN'T IN FASHION.
AGAIN, JIM.
>> GERMAN CHANCELLOR ANGELA
MERKEL HAS A GREAT SENSE OF
HUMOR.
>> Stephen: YOU HEARD IT,
FOLKS.
HILLARY CLINTON THINKS GERMAN
CHANCELLORS ARE A LAUGH RIOT.
HEIL HILARITY.
>> HERE, BONO SITS WITH ME AT
THE PIANO.
>> Stephen: BIG DEAL!
BONO SITS WITH EVERYBODY AT THE
PIAPO.
CALL ME WHEN YOU'RE SITTING WITH
DAVID BOWIE AT A DIDGERIDOO.
I JUST DON'T BUY ANY OF THIS.
THERE IS NO WAY ON EARTH
ONE WOMAN CAN BE IN SO MANY
PLACES AT ONCE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
(AUDIENCE CHANTING "HILLARY")
>> Stephen: DON'T YOU DARE!
DON'T YOU DARE!
YOU WERE CHANTING MY NAME FOUR
MINUTES AGO, YOU TWO-TIMERS.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> NOW WHO'S A NAME DROPPER,
STEPHEN?
>> Stephen: OH, REALLY?
NAME DROPPER?
THAT'S NOT WHAT MY GOOD FRIEND
TOM HANKS CALLS ME.
WHEN WE'RE HANGING OUT AT GEORGE
CLOONEY'S PLACE.
>> OH, I LOVE GEORGE.
I WISH HE COULD HAVE JOINED US
WHEN I HAD LUNCH WITH MERYL
STREEP AND ECUADORIAN PRESIDENT
RAFAEL CORREA.
>> OH, RAFI.
HE IS SUCH A CUT-UP, ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE GO CAMPING WITH OPRAH.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> OH?
>> DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU?
>> NO, "O" IS JUST WHAT ALL HER
REAL FRIENDS CALL OPRAH.
>> Stephen: I KNOW PAUL
MCCARTNEY
>> I NEGOTIATED WITH HAMID
KARZAI.
>> Stephen: I SHARED AN
OFFICE WITH STEVE CARELL.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> I HELD HIGH-LEVEL TALKS WITH
CHINESE STATE COUNSELOR
DAI BINGGUO
>> Stephen: WELL, NOW YOU'RE
JUST MAKING WORDS UP.
I WILL HAVE YOU KNOW, MADAM, I
ONCE DID AN ENTIRE SHOW WITH
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON.
>> OH!
( APPLAUSE )
I HATE TO BREAK THIS TO YOU,
STEPHEN, BUT I'VE MET HIM, TOO.
>> Stephen: GOSH, YOU KNOW
EVERYONE!
WHAT KIND OF LOSER DO YOU HAVE
TO BE TO NOT BE INCLUDED IN YOUR
BOOK?
>> WELL, YOU'RE NOT IN IT,
STEPHEN?
>> Stephen: OH, AREN'T I?
YOU EVER NOTICE HOW PRESIDENT OF
TURKMENISTAN GURBANGULY
BERD-MUHA-MEADOW ARE NEVER IN
THE SAME ROOM AT THE SAME TIME.
>> NO!
>> Stephen: OH, YES.
>> Stephen: AND, MADAM, IT IS
NOT JUST YOUR NAME DROPPING I
CALL INTO QUESTION.
I QUESTION YOUR TITLE.
IT'S CALLED "HARD CHOICES."
BUT THERE AREN'T ANY REAL HARD
CHOICES IN HERE.
>> WHAT ABOUT NEGOTIATING
FRAGILE ALLIANCES AND TREATIES.
>> Stephen: OH, I'M TALKING
ABOUT REAL HARD CHOICES--
ETERNAL QUESTIONS LIKE WHICH
WOULD YOU RATHER FIGHT ONE
HORSE-SIZED DUCK OR 100
DUCK-SIZED HORSES?
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
>> WELL --
>> Stephen: BOOM!
>> NOW, I ADMIT THAT IS A VALID
QUESTION.
HERE'S WHAT I'D DO.
FIRST, I'D TRY TO FIND COMMON
GROUND BETWEEN DUCKS AND HORSES.
FOR INSTANCE, THEY BOTH GREW UP
ON OLD McDONALD'S FARM.
THEN, I'D ESTABLISH A TIMETABLE
TO ACHIEVE MEANINGFUL HORSE-DUCK
DIALOGUE.
( LAUGHTER )
AND, STEPHEN, I'M CONVINCED--
WITH PATIENCE AND A STRONG
COMMITMENT FROM OUR ALLIES, THE
PIGS AND THE GEESE, WE'D HAVE
PEACE-PEACE HERE, PEACE-PEACE,
THERE, HERE A PEACE, THERE A
PEACE, EVERYWHERE A PEACE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
>> Stephen: EI-E-I-OH, YOU'RE
GOOD!
>> AND NOW, STEPHEN, I'VE GOT A
HARD CHOICE FOR YOU.
>> Stephen: BRING IT, H.R.C.
>> OH, IT WILL BE BROUGHT.
YOUR CHOICE.
PROMOTE MY BOOK OR I WON'T
APPEAR ON YOUR SHOW.
>> Stephen: BUT YOU HAVE
ALREADY APPEARED ON MY SHOW.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Stephen: NO!
NO!
>>I LEARNED THAT FROM GEORGE
LUCAS.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> Stephen: I MET HIM.
HE'S A FRIEND.
WELL, NO ONE WILL KNOW I GOT
HILLARY CLINTON ON MY SHOW.
FINE!
BUY "HARD CHOICES," AVAILABLE IN
BOOKSTORES EVERYWHERE THERE ARE
STILL BOOKSTORES.
ON OR OUR WEB SITE DOWN HERE,
OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> Stephen: OH, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, STEPHEN.
WAS THAT SUCH A HARD CHOICE TO
MAKE?
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> Stephen: YES, IT WAS.
HILLARY CLINTON, EVERYBODY.
"HARD CHOICES."
MADAM SECRETARY, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
>> THANK YOU!
>> Stephen: HILLARY CLINTON,
EVERYBODY.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).